the fake impeachment trial is officially
about to begin both sides have submitted
their briefs
very important to note from the outset
this is
not an impeachment trial this does not
meet
the constitutional standards of an
impeachment trial
they are not trying the president they
are trying an ex-president
the chief justice is not presiding
they've just got some dem senator
presiding
it is not an impeachment trial
nevertheless they're going to pretend
that it is
the house has submitted their arguments
their arguments are
in just a few words that donald trump is
singularly responsible for the riot at
the capitol which was an
insurrection and therefore we've got to
remove him from the office he's already
left
the trump argument and the trump legal
team has submitted their briefs
is that president trump is no longer the
president he didn't incite an
insurrection and the whole thing is a
farce
so they're going to be making this
constitutional argument that none of
this
is legitimate whatsoever that is a timid
and i don't want to say a timid argument
it's a modest argument it's a smaller
argument
it's not making claims about voter fraud
it's not making claims about the biden
administration
so the question for all of us is will
this trump impeachment trial
fake or real be the greatest show on
earth
will it be trumpian will it keep us all
glued to our seats
or will it fizzle out i'm michael
knowles it's the michael knowles show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from yesterday is from chris
chris1985
who's quoting jen saki white house press
secretary when she says i hate to
disappoint conservative twitter
what is conservative twitter never heard
of it well actually that's a great point
because there obviously they are
referring to the conservatives on
twitter
who get kicked off more and more each
day and silenced and shadow abandoned
censored
now some people tried to create a
separate conservative twitter
but the left would not tolerate that
they want us to be tame
they want us to be easily controlled
they want us to be pliable
some republicans even in republican
leadership are going along with that
some are not and it's why this
impeachment issue even if it's a fake
impeachment trial that's why this
impeachment issue and this trump issue
is going to have a very
very very long tail
if you want to know what's happening in
the future if you want to understand
what's happening in the present
you can't do all of that without some
knowledge of what's happening in the
past
that a knowledge of history you can't do
that without a basic knowledge of oh i
don't know
mathematics a basic knowledge of
language a basic knowledge of
everything that we need to make sense of
our world one great way to do it
the great courses plus with the great
courses plus you have unlimited access
to thousands of video and audio courses
on hundreds of fascinating topics you
can learn a new language
you can discover what einstein got wrong
you can even gain
valuable insights into your own public
persona there is something for everyone
i myself
recommend checking out their new course
1066
the year that changed everything what
changed in 1066
well you're gonna have to check out the
great courses to find out i
am really really pleased that i found
this new way to be more productive with
my
time and i want you to try the great
courses plus
too you can one one aspect of this that
i think is really terrific
you can start by listening to it right
you're listening to the great courses on
your phone
then you continue watching on your tv
then you can watch it on your computer
it's just you can move it around it's
really a really
great way to spend any of that free time
you've got
the great courses plus will offer you a
free month of unlimited
access at this url the
ratecoursesplus.com
knowles that is a whole month to learn
anything you want for free
sign up now that is
thegreatcoursesplus.com
knowles i love the great courses plus go
check
them out trump never seems to go away
trump i'm glad i miss trump i'm sort of
glad we're going to get to see him on tv
the left has completely shut him up
de-platformed him take him taken him out
of life but they can't let him all go
all at one because they need him for
some reason
trump represents something that will not
go away represents
he he represents this debate over the
direction of the republican party
and ultimately the direction of the
country
now you know there is someone in house
republican leadership
who voted to impeach donald trump
i know this seems completely insane that
the republican party which
overwhelmingly supports donald trump
still
majority of republicans according to
recent polls want him to be the nominee
in 2024
okay i i as far as i can tell
unprecedented
sort of support for this guy within his
own party
someone in the leadership of the
republican party in the house would
would vote for his impeachment seems
strange that would be liz cheney
now mitch mcconnell senate majority
leader has come out and defended liz
cheney
he says liz cheney is a leader with deep
convictions and the courage to act on
them
okay that's it that's all you can muster
barack obama is is a leader with deep
convictions and the courage to act on
them
he is a leader some people took issue
with this when i pointed it out
on the internet he said no he's not a
leader he's a terrible person
terrible people can be leaders world
history is
is rife with examples of that he's
he's a leader he led he was president of
the united states he won reelection he
changed the country he was
extraordinarily influential he has deep
convictions and he had the courage to
act on them
that in and of itself does not qualify
somebody to be in republican leadership
the question is what what are the
convictions
the question is where are you leading
your followers
and the question for for regarding liz
cheney right now is
do republicans believe that this woman
and her convictions and her leadership
best represents their party
it's hard to imagine how in a way it
it's quite courageous that liz cheney
just hated trump so much he felt so
convicted about this issue of
impeachment that she she decided she had
to vote
to impeach the republican president i
think it was a stupid vote i don't i
i do not think in in any reasonable
world he committed an impeachable
offense
a second to impeachable offense don't
forget it was the second impeachment
vote against trump but fine liz cheney
thinks that that's fine
if she's going to take that courageous
vote she's got to deal with the
consequences namely
she is not fit for republican leadership
she does not represent the views of the
republican party
she might represent the views of a
certain type of leadership class you see
george w bush came out and defended liz
cheney mitch mcconnell now defending liz
cheney
fine i'm not saying kick her out of
congress i'm not saying kick her out of
the republican party
in a way it's sort of admirable that she
has that courage of her convictions it's
too bad because her reasoning was
extremely flawed
in when she took that vote but fine
great she's got that courage
got those convictions now you need to
deal with the consequences of that
it's preposterous and presumably she's
going to remain in leadership i don't
see a
major revolt the only congressman the
only prominent
republican who's really come out and
said liz cheney doesn't belong in
leadership is matt gates
but assuming that's not enough assuming
she stays in leadership
this is going to increase the divide
between the gop leadership class
and the gop base
your courage matters and your leadership
matters but you need to have the right
convictions
this is something we've talked about a
lot on the show how we've tricked
ourselves for many years into thinking
that
all that mattered was the form of
politics
the substance of the politics didn't
matter so we just we support
free speech we don't support saying
anything in particular but we just
we just support free speech we support
religious liberty we don't believe in
anything ourselves but we just support
religious liberty
that's not enough the left has form and
substance in their politics and it's
really dangerous but it's very effective
and we need to get a little bit more
courage give you an example of one of
the radicals in the democratic party
rafael warnock
this uh radical leftist
a socialist who when he was helping to
run
a church invited fidel castro
to go there who said that you can't
serve god in the u.s military
who said many many radical things in his
life
rafael warnock just came out and said
that we need to institute widespread
unsolicited mail-in votes
for ever we this is essential
to voting integrity he pushed back
against
uh people who were trying to do the
opposite he said this is shameful
we need to swiftly pass the for the
people act what
goodness gracious in the whole scope of
shameless legislation names and a lot of
them are pretty shameless
for the people act give me a break to
strengthen
access to the ballot and prevent voter
suppression
from silencing our voices we republicans
need to get serious about this and get
tough
and it's going to require us to actually
put our convictions on the table
and come out and say we need to get rid
of widespread mailings
make them illegal in places we need to
get rid of the drop boxes for the
ballots
make those illegal we need to take
election season
and get rid of all those extra days
where you can vote and make it election
day
again this is possibly an existential
matter
for our representative government and i
know a lot of republicans are not going
to want to do it because here's what
they're going to say
they're going to say michael if with all
these things
all the mail-in and the dropbox and you
know you start voting 18 months before
election day if that will encourage even
one more person to vote
well don't we have to do that just to
ink because
we have to increase the voting
for everybody people who are unwilling
to get themselves out of bed and
actually vote on election day we need we
need them to vote
no we don't we don't and all of that is
sort of a facade to cover up the purpose
of these measures which is actually
to to get rid of election integrity
we need to come out there and be able to
say that now
the most persuasive argument for this i
think is that
every illegal vote that is cast
disenfranchises a legal voter
so actually the real voter suppression
is getting rid of election integrity and
promoting fraud
but i don't know that the the persuasion
is really the key here
do you ever notice this with the left
the left has such radical plans i mean
within the first week and week or two
weeks in
in joe biden's administration he
obliterated girls sports and the women's
bathroom right through executive order
not very popular stuff but the left
doesn't
care because what the left lacks in
persuasive power
they make up for more than make up for
in the willingness to exercise the
political power
that they've given or that they've
outright taken
and republicans don't have that we oh we
love persuading
we love talking about the free
marketplace of ideas we love think tanks
we love debates we love all that sort of
stuff
i i i'm persuading right now right this
is one of the few areas that
conservatives have
any sort of leverage in is in certain
small segments of alternative media
but what about the elected guys what
about the guys working in the government
why can't they do their job namely the
exercise of the political power that
they've been given
because we can persuade and persuade and
persuade until we're blue in the face
if we're not willing to actually
exercise political power that will all
be for naught
and if we don't fix this election
integrity issue we're not we're not
going to have very much political power
in the future at least not in the races
that count there's a headline
out of 538 there's a nate silvers
publication
it's called where did all the bellwether
counties go
here ryan matsumoto who is the the
author
is examining how all those bellwether
counties that have predicted the
presidential elections for decades
the vast majority of them somehow got it
wrong in 2020.
isn't that a little strange what does
that say about the 2020 election we'll
get to
exactly what it does say because the
answer doesn't have to be
conspiratorial it's right actually it's
right in front of our faces
this is a time of great instability and
it's instability in politics it's
instability in the stock market we've
seen
it's a great time to look into investing
in precious metals here's something new
you know that the price of gold has been
skyrocketing
lately well there is a new way to buy
gold through a company called acre acre
lets you subscribe to gold bars for as
little as
30 dollars a month you pay each month
once your gold stash reaches the price
of their gold bars
they will discreetly ship acre gold to
your house great way to invest in gold
when you think
you know borrow gold costs a ton of
money and i don't have a ton of money
lying around well
now you can invest in that kind of
physical gold in a way that will work
for you
also you know how there's a nationwide
shortage of ammo right now
well acre is crafting i kid you not a
solid gold 24 karat
nine millimeter bullet you cannot find
anything like these on the internet
they're only making a thousand of these
so they're going fast uh these
are the first products coming out of
acres new special products division
uh to be clear these are not shootable
bullets i don't know why you'd want to
shoot a solid gold bullet out unless
you're trying to kill a werewolf or
something but
i would just i would just keep it it's a
nice investment looks really cool
visit getacregold.com michael and start
investing in physical gold today make
sure
you go to this url because acre is
giving away a gold bar to qualify for
the giveaway
i just tweet or post why you should be
the recipient mention
at get underscore acre that is
gettiergold.com
michael thank you aker gold for
supporting the show you know i've i've
mentioned that i have enjoyed
uh keeping a portion of my portfolio in
precious metals a lot of conservatives
enjoy that
now more than ever i think it's a pretty
uh pretty appealing option
go check out acre gold
so 538 wants to know where did all the
bellwether counties go
from 1980 to 2016 19 counties voted for
the winner of the presidential election
every single time
the most impressive of those was
valencia county new mexico
which voted for the victor in every
presidential election from 1952
to 2016. but in 2020
18 of these 19 bellwether counties
voted for donald trump just one
claim county was washington voted
for joe biden so
then they spend lots and lots of ink
asking where did the bellwether counties
go
where do they all isn't that so weird
facts like this will buttress
people who have questions about the
presidential election
questions about uh you know boxes of
ballots in georgia
and pipes bursting and all these sorts
of irregularities
thousands of votes you know accidentally
being
missed or discounted or they're only
added later
gonna add a lot of uh fuel to those
to that fire of uh election doubt
however i'm i'm i'm not discounting that
you know if there's evidence of these
things happening and it being widespread
we've talked about this on the show a
lot
more than open to to looking at that
evidence
hope hope there is evidence hope we
could see it but obviously even if there
were it's very difficult to show this
stuff even even in 1948
you know i keep going back to this
election because it's so famous and so
consequential
lbj stole a senate seat in texas this
has been extraordinarily well documented
most recently by robert carrow who is
sort of the preeminent
lbj biographer he uh notes this in means
of ascent 1948
lbj who had been stealing elections
since college who'd been stealing
elections for his
staff club presidency at when he was
working as a staffer on capitol hill
uh this guy stole the the election by
stuffing the ballot boxes in texas
uh he won by a statistically impossible
margin
he then this goes up to the supreme
court the supreme court won't even look
into it they just say we don't have
jurisdiction here
goes back to the state lbj becomes
senator lbj becomes vice president lbj
becomes president lbj
dies and then all those years later they
say look at that it was a fraudulent
vote so sure these things happen
however there's a simpler answer here to
what's going on with these bellwether
counties
let's say forget about all the theories
that various people have
posited about the voting machines and
even about
pipes bursting and even about thumb is
going missing whatever
just consider this we changed all the
election rules weeks and months before
the election
right in in places that mattered we
radically
upended the election rules in
pennsylvania in contravention of the
state constitution
so even if even if there's nothing
behind the scenes
hidden nefarious going on is it any
wonder that if you
change the rules of the election you're
going to have
different outcomes in bellwether
counties the bellwether counties are
only bellwether
in normal elections right in elections
where the rules remain the same
if you completely change the rules of
the game then those counties aren't
going to tell you anything they are
fine-tuned
to tell you about the old rules but what
the left did is they went in and
completely changed the rules to make
them advantageous
to themselves and and harmful to us
and we don't even have the hutzpah to
come out and say hey get rid of the
widespread mailing
get rid of election month get rid of all
that they
reoriented the system so that it would
be
more advantageous to them that
is what politicians do
in a way you have to admire it just just
like you have to admire the
people who have leadership and
convictions and courage who are on the
other side
it's very bad for the country but you
say well at least you're exercising
political power
what are our guys doing absolutely
absolutely
nothing and for the handful of people
who come out and say guys this is wrong
we need to look into this i'm going to
object to some of these votes i'm
talking about guys like ted cruz
josh hawley other people
what does the left say the left comes
out tries to ruin their careers
aoc i kid you not came out she's been
calling ted cruz and josh hawley
murderers
because she says she came out early on
and said that
nearly half the members of congress were
killed
in in the riot at the capitol of course
no member of congress was even injured
but just they were all
almost half of us were killed and then
she said ted cruz is trying to murder me
and now she's saying that guys like cruz
and hawley are tantamount to rapists
i'm a survivor of sexual assault
um and i haven't told many people that
in my life
when i see a party
who cheered on violence
violence that killed five maybe now six
people a second capital police officer
took their life
in the aftermath of the attack
um this past week these people are just
trying to tell us
it's not a big deal and they're trying
to say
you're making too big a deal over it
or my favorite
um this past week
ted cruz and now representatives chip
roy and
oh by the way some of the other
representatives who actually encouraged
people to threaten members of congress
or tweeted out the location of the
speaker
are now telling me to apologize for
saying and speaking truth
to what happened these are the tactics
of abusers
or rather these are the tactics that
abusers use
i don't know why she makes that
distinction because it means the same
thing so she's saying
ted cruz because he followed a
constitutional process
and uh voiced his objections to
some of the irregularities on the record
uh he's a murderer
he tried to murder me and when
cruz and hawley and some of these other
guys came out and said
okay apologize to us you can't call us
murderers
that's so wrong she says oh yeah you're
rapists too
she says i was i was sexually assaulted
i've never told anybody this but i was
sexually assaulted
and you are just like rapists
so i guess the firs the breaking news
here is that aoc says she was sexually
assaulted
uh the question you have to ask is is
that true
maybe maybe it was true i don't know if
if
people make that kind of a claim it's a
claim you want to take seriously
the trouble with aoc is that she's a
pathological liar
she's lied brazenly about not just
public policy in a way that even
politifact has given you know politifact
is a left-wing outlet
even they have given her uh some
difficult ratings because she's just
lied about i don't know defense spending
or immigration enforcement
she's lied about the apocalypse saying
the world's going to end in 12 years but
but
even more to the point here she's lied
about core aspects of her biography
that very few people pointed out i
actually i was one of the few people
that was able to point this out
because i grew up in the town next to
aoc at
exactly the same time so aoc when she
was campaigning
pretended that she was raised in the
bronx she was not when she was very very
little she lived in the bronx but then
she grew up
in one of the wealthiest counties in the
country i know this because i lived in
the town right next door
and she lived in the town that was
wealthier than my town and she went to
very very good schools
and then for college she went to a very
expensive private school so she was
portraying herself as jenny from the
block
she got called out for it and she's
never given a good answer on that so
is this story that she's telling true or
not it could be but it's just
you can't take it as gospel truth when
somebody has a proven track record of
lying even about fundamental aspects
of her biography the other reason that
we have to be skeptical here is because
she's being so flippant
she's being so glib about what i think
is a serious issue
right rape is a pretty serious issue
guys
it's a about as serious as they get and
she
is using this i mean we've never heard
about before she's using it as just a
cudgel
to attack chip roy and ted cruz
she's saying you guys are like rapists
that's not the language of somebody who
takes that issue seriously so she won't
take it seriously i will take it
seriously
she'll trot it out for a cheap political
shot i i want to i want to take it much
more seriously i think than the left
does
because there is uh right now
a group of women who are accusing
marilyn manson this uh
you know pretty famous rock star from
the 90s and i guess he's still pretty
famous
they're they're accusing him of abuse
and this term sexual assault which has
only been popularized in recent decades
so it's broader than the term rape but
it does raise big questions about our
sort of
sexual environment about our legal
regime on this question
and on on what where where exactly
the the problems really begin because
the left has all the wrong answers on
this
uh but i think if we if we pursue the
issue a little bit
you'll you'll see where the seeds of
this kind of culture were planted
because in a way i can't believe i'm
saying this
in a way the left has a point they just
don't have the point they think
that they have we'll get to that in one
second you know
if you want to check out misinformation
if you want to check out the people
telling lies
you need to look no further than the
current occupants of the white house and
yet ironically
the white house is saying they're going
to crack down on misinformation you can
hear about this on ben's show
he will break it down point by point
earlier this month you know we released
our first film run hide fight
this was exclusively for daily wire
members uh you can now catch it over at
dailywire.com on our mobile app
on our streaming app at apple tv roku if
you're not a daily wire member yet if
you use
promo code rhf to get 25 off you can
join you can watch the whole movie it's
got like a zero percent critic score but
it's got like a 93
audience score go to rhf for 25
off we'll be right back with a lot more
so there is a group of women accusing
marilyn manson
of sexual assault evan rachel wood who
is an actress i've actually never seen
her work
but she and i got into some kind of
twitter spat one time and
so that's the only way i became aware of
her but she is probably the most
prominent person
uh leading this charge other women are
doing it too though
we'll get into those accusations because
i actually think
that no matter how sort of
cheapened this this debate has become uh
the the left does
kind of have a point here i just want to
zoom out for a second
marilyn manson he took his stage name
from marilyn monroe and charles manson
one of the most famous killers in
american history
marilyn manson the highest profile
satanist in america
he was friends with anton levay who was
the head of the church of satan
he described himself as a minister in
the church of satan
he was a devotee of alistair crowley
maybe the the other most famous satanist
of the last hundred years
he quotes crowley in his autobiography
says that
crowley's sort of central dictum is very
important to him which is
do what thou wilt shall be the whole of
the law
a lot of other references to crowley
turns out the satanist abuses people
not exactly a man bites dog
story but it is in our culture because
we we have
so lost our perspective on these things
that we would be shocked we say oh
there's there's nothing strange about
being a satanist no it's fine it's
actually good that's all the same
we can't discriminate you see this in
lawsuits often you'll have some
satanists
suing a church or suing rather a
courthouse
is they have the ten commandments we say
that the church of satan
and the actual church the christian
church they're sort of the same thing we
can't
we have to be neutral between those two
our founding fathers rolling over in our
in their graves on this
but let's get into the actual
accusations
viewer discretion if people are uh
younger right now listening to this
maybe just close their ears for about
a minute or two evan rachel wood before
she said that she was abused by marilyn
manson
testified before congress and said she
was abused by a sort of
former ex-boyfriend you know who
she's going to leave nameless here is
her description of the abuse
my experience with domestic violence was
this toxic mental physical and sexual
abuse which started slow but escalated
over time including threats against my
life
severe gaslighting and brainwashing
waking up to the man that claimed to
love me raping what he believed to be my
unconscious body
and the worst part sick rituals of
binding me up by my hands and feet
to be mentally and physically tortured
until my abuser felt i had proven my
love for them
in this moment while i was tied up and
being beaten and being told
unspeakable things i truly felt like i
could die not just because my abuser
said to me i could kill you right now
but because in that moment i felt like i
left my body and i was too afraid to run
he would find me i froze
and it was as if i could see myself from
the outside and for the first time in
months i felt something
utter shame and despair i had no idea
what to do to change my situation so i
went numb
and soon i couldn't feel anything i
wasn't alive my self-esteem and spirit
were broken
okay pretty ugly stuff uh jenna jameson
who is a former porn star
who dated manson sort of at the height
of his fame didn't describe anything
like that but she did say he
he bit her you know he was very into
like biting and
sort of a bruising and painful way and
uh said
that he had fantasies about burning her
alive so i guess it does kind of jibe a
little bit with what evan rachel what is
describing
about the unnamed ex-boyfriend
there are two important parts of this
story
that show how modern liberal culture
exacerbates all of this stuff
right these left-wing
women are not complaining other than aoc
taking a cheap political shot that has
nothing to do with the actual issue
these women are not complaining
generally speaking about conservative
men marilyn manson is not exactly a
you know a conservative republican or
something
they're complaining about people who
buy into this leftist idea the metoo
movement
is focusing on all these leftist dudes
from the sort of least serious
accusations you think of like aziz
ansari
where they're basically describing this
like very grass bad date
or all the way up to harvey weinstein
these guys are liberal democrats right
so it's
whatever the issue is if it has a
political dimension the political
dimension is going to be on the left
in the case of jenna jameson's
descriptions here and in the case at
least in part of
evan rachel wood the sick behavior
that they're describing was consensual
right when evan rachel wood's talking
about and we had this ritual that we
would do
so we'd do it multiple times right if
it's a ritual where he'd tie me up and
beat me and
say all these horrible terrible things
to me
and i didn't it was ruining my
self-esteem but that was obviously
consensual and there are even many
people
on the right now certainly the left says
this but even many people on the right
who say
look if it's consensual it's totally
cool that is the highest
political good is consent look if as
long as you two
consent to it you can do whatever you
want there's nothing about it but
actual conservatives conservatives who
understand that there's a transcendent
moral order
realize no things can be done
consensually that are still extremely
wrong
on paper what not the first part about
waking up but
all the the rituals whatever rachel wood
is describing was consensual and it was
still wrong
and it was wrong for her to consent to
it i suppose i mean it wrong just
because of how it obviously hurt her and
tore her up inside
but it was wrong for the dude even if he
got consent
to do it it just remains wrong consent
is not enough
there is a higher good than consent the
second aspect of this though
that that sort of overturns this leftist
prevailing notion about sex is
this shows that sex is not a casual
thing
the culture that we're all living in the
ubiquitous culture especially on college
campuses but especially just among young
single people
is that sex is kind of casual it's
basically like a handshake well now
handshakes are illegal
because of covid but so i guess it's
even more casual than a handshake
and it's totally fine you go and you
just hook up with whoever you want and
then
next day is no big deal and nobody gets
hurt because it's consensual right it
does tie into that issue
and that's just obviously not true and
here's how i'll show you it's not true
the punishments for sexual assault are
more severe than punishments for simple
assault
right if i if i go up to some dude on
the street or we're in a bar or
something
and we're talking and we're getting
angry and i punch that guy in the face
i'll get in trouble you know that
involves some punishments
but the punishments are not as severe as
rape
why because sex is not just a casual
thing
if it were simple assault and sexual
assault would be indistinguishable
but sex is a very serious thing it's
very significant
and it's not even purely a physical
phenomenon
it has a spiritual component too and i
know that liberals and the modern left
in particular
and even some segments of the right who
are a little more licentious
don't want to admit any of that because
i don't know because some of this stuff
is fun you know
when it's happening and when everyone's
doing it but nevertheless that is true
there are these scare tactics that go
around like college campuses and they've
become very popular over the last
30 40 years this the statistics you'll
hear is that one in four women or one in
five women
on college campuses will be sexually
assaulted while they're there they'll be
raped while they're on campus
that is obviously not true if that were
true no parent would ever send
his kid or her kid to college
right you wouldn't could you if someone
said hey we've we uh
we've got a great place where your
daughter can
read aristotle they're probably not
anymore they'll probably read ibram
candy or something now
but we got a great place where your
daughter can go she reads some books
you'll get a credential
one in four chance though that she'll be
the victim of rape
would anybody if anybody actually
believe that would they say oh okay sign
me where do i sign up
oh and i get to pay a quarter million
dollars for the privilege great terrific
no of course nobody believes that but
those numbers
come from uh these sort of activist
surveys i detail some of this actually
in my upcoming book speechless
controlling words controlling minds
which you can pre-order now it's not
coming out for a few months though
one of the tricks to some of these
surveys is that they'll ask women
describe these experiences
describe if you believe you're a victim
of rape or sexual assault
and then they'll they will after the
fact
define many women who do not think that
they're victims of rape
as victims of rape and the reason that
they'll do this
or rather the the theory that they're
pushing as they do this
is this idea of false consciousness
which is a marxist idea
that became very prominent in the 1970s
with second wave feminism it's become
very uh prominent with the rise of
things like critical race theory which
people have been talking about
over the past few months that you you
are not aware
of your own oppression so you need to
have your consciousness raised
this was a ritual of the new york
radical women's groups
and uh when your consciousness is raised
you'll realize how oppressed you are
there's
actually a funny essay about this where
a woman describes
how she she went to a new york radical
women's consciousness raising party
she says you know when i showed up i was
totally happy i was just a regular
housewife i was totally happy
only by the end did i realize how
oppressed i am
and thank goodness for that women's
group you think well
did you really get your money's worth
there it doesn't seem like a great way
to spend
time so the statistics are crazy no
nobody really believes that harvard yard
is more dangerous to women than downtown
baghdad right
nobody seriously believes that but it's
about redefining all of those terms
well as they've done so they've also
redefined
what would be by any normal standard
abusive sex as perfectly fine and dandy
and
kind of fun and kinky and consensual
but the testimony we're seeing just just
with regarding
or just with regard to the marilyn
manson case the testimony we're seeing
is
no that can still be abusive as well and
i think it's just
we've got to shake this is part and
parcel of something we've been talking
about for a couple weeks now
we've got to stop pretending that
consent is the be-all and end-all
there is something higher it's not even
just
it ties in with the idea that it's not
just that we protect freedom of speech
that's great
you need something to say you need to
believe certain things
and exclude other things it's not just
about consent you have to
it depends what you're consenting to the
the acts themselves really matter
speaking of strange sex
and double standards on all of this
twitter
is uh permitting the turkish interior
minister to remain
on their platform even though the
turkish interior minister said very
offensive things about gay guys he
tweeted out
should we tolerate the lgbt deviants who
insult the great kaaba
of course not that was interior minister
suleiman
soyiloo referring to a shrine in mecca
now
should we take down this guy's tweet i
don't really care right i don't what do
i care about the turkish interior
minister
however what i what i do care about
regardless of his culture or his
country or the minister of turkey
i care that twitter is going to let that
tweet remain up
but they're going to take down the
tweets of the
duly elected sitting president of the
united states at the time donald trump
and not just that they're going to take
them off the platform
twitter is going to give greater
deference
to the interior minister of turkey than
they are to the president of the united
states
and actually one thing i really love
about this story is it shows
that the left does not particularly care
about say lgbt people or
whatever fashionable grievance group
they're focusing on at the time
they care about the exercise of power
they're just
they're it's it's just a negative
campaign against the united states
against tradition so
this guy tweets out this offensive thing
about lgbt
people but it doesn't
if they take him down that's not gonna
look good it's gonna look like
wow maybe the united states it has a
better view on something than people
around the world and so we're not gonna
we're just gonna leave it up
we're just gonna leave it up and it's
better it's in the in the public
interest to leave up
these states men oh well you don't
really believe that because you took
down donald trump
which is why i am so sick and tired of
hearing about cancer culture
i'm sick and tired of hearing about it
cancel culture is a slogan and like all
slogans it
refers to something real but the slogan
itself should be basically disregarded
kind of like pro-life you'll hear people
say this they'll say
you're pro-life huh yeah yeah but you
support the death penalty what a
hypocrite
no pro-life refers to one specific thing
refers to
opposition to killing babies in the womb
there are other questions about
life that come up i don't i don't
believe that we
i still think the civil authority has
the right to kill criminals i
don't think that we can eradicate death
right i guess if i were really pro-life
i would want to abolish death well
you can't abolish death right it doesn't
mean any of those things
it's a slogan that refers to a specific
thing we can talk about those other
things later
but that's not what we're talking about
here same thing with cancer culture
cancer culture refers to a specific
phenomenon of leftist censorship
and ostracism of anyone who contradicts
politically correct orthodoxy
have conservatives censored liberals
before yes
mccarthyism is a great example
mccarthyism a very good thing perhaps
perhaps we'll get we'll get to that at
some later point
but sure yeah it absolutely does that
mean that we can say whatever we want
whenever we want there's no limits on
free speech no that's never been true in
america but we're talking about
something specific
the issue that that is going on right
now is not conservative censoring
leftists
it's the opposite so let's focus on that
issue but the left doesn't want to have
that honest argument
it's why they resort to these cheap ugly
tactics you see it from aoc
you see it from all sorts of bad faith
actors on the internet in the public
square and there's no reason to engage
in that debate
no debate in that context is possible
blm has been nominated for a nobel peace
prize
some people are calling it the nobel
mostly peaceful prize
i think that is probably true everyone
is very upset because blm obviously was
torching the country for like six months
it doesn't seem very peaceful however
i think this is pretty in keeping with
uh with past winners you've got uh
yasser arafat yazer a
terrorist from the middle east right uh
he won
so surely if he won blm can win two
beyond that you've got barack obama one
barack obama started multiple new wars
al gore won the nobel peace prize
and he didn't start any wars as far as i
can tell but
he he has supported a campaign of uh
population suppression he has supported
uh abortion and contraception in the
third world to keep africans from having
too many babies
that doesn't seem peaceful jimmy carter
jim carter didn't start
any new wars kind of feckless i don't
even bring a bring a ton of peace but
fair enough
so sure blm is uh is up for this
a lot of conservatives are saying we
should not nominate blm for this i would
like to go further
and this ties in to cancel culture i
think blm
should be cancelled we should not permit
that organization to operate in the
united states it is a subversive
organization
it is not only opposed to the structure
of the us government
but it actively tries to overturn those
structures by setting government
buildings on fire
by burning down businesses by torching
city after city after city
it is opposed in idea to the united
states and it is opposed in practice to
the united states
because it attacks law enforcement and
because it attacks
all of these sorts of institutions it is
a subversive organization
it should be prosecuted under the smith
act we were just talking about
mccarthyism
the smith act is an act that was
popular and actually used in the mid
20th century before the supreme court
watered it down
to prosecute communists because you
can't be an open subversive you can't
actively be trying to overturn the
system we can't we can't tolerate
that that amount of uh
of free expression this sort of
expression that's going to overturn the
entire system
of free expression can't have it like
chesterton said there's a thought that
stops thought
that's the only thought that ought to be
stopped same with antifa we should not
tolerate antifa you might say michael
you're an authoritarian
your views sound so my views are not in
any way authoritarian
we've had these kinds of rules against
sedition and subversive organizations
since the very beginning of the country
my views are no more authoritarian than
thomas jefferson's my views are no more
authoritarian than john lockes who wrote
the letter concerning toleration
in the letter concerning toleration john
locke says atheists under no
circumstances should ever be tolerated
john locke is the father of liberalism
so i just don't want to hear it i don't
want to hear about illiberalism
i don't want to hear about
authoritarianism we need
to have substance this goes all the way
back
to mitch mcconnell's defense of liz
cheney where he says you know she has
convictions
and she leads and she has courage
yeah so does blm blm they lead they have
courage
they have convictions what matters
is what the convictions are
and if the convictions are opposed to
the country itself
those cannot be tolerated
we want specific action i think we're
finally waking up out of this slumber
of just lulling ourselves to sleep to do
nothing politically
for for a couple of decades
conservatives are realizing oh we
actually have to wield political power
ron desantis down in florida is
realizing this he just came out and
announced big actions on big tech
in florida we're going to take action
we're going to take aim at those
companies and pull back the veil and
make sure these guys don't continue to
find loopholes
and gray areas to live above the law
under our proposal if a technology
company deep platforms a candidate for
elected office in florida
during an election a company will face a
daily fine of a hundred thousand dollars
until the candidates access to the
platform
is restored again any floridian can d
platform any candidate they choose
you simply unsubscribe and it's a right
that i believe belongs with the citizen
further if a technology company promotes
a candidate for office against another
the value of that free promotion must be
recorded as a political campaign
contribution
enforced by the florida elections
commission and lastly
a technology company uses their content
and user-related algorithms to suppress
or prioritize
the access of any content related to a
political candidate or cause on the
ballot
that company will also face daily fines
love this this is actually the perfect
issue
to see what we're all talking about here
is on one level what desantis is doing
is very pro
free speech right pro free expression
he's saying
if you d-platform people who are running
for office in the way that big tech did
to donald trump right because it's not
just even kicking the candidates off
it's suppressing the news stories it's
taking away the hunter biden story which
twitter did in the run-up to the
election it's then after the election
while it was being contested kicking
trump off of
the platform in that way very pro-free
speech
but in another way it's this is
authoritarian this is illiberal
this is suppressing the speech of the
tech companies build your own twitter
build your own google no that's just
bunk that's ridiculous give me a break
big tech controls the flow of
information around the internet
the internet is the public square big
tech controls
our political discourse effectively
and if they are putting their finger on
the scale we need to go in
if we regulate them as ron desantis is
doing
that is not an attack on free speech
that is a defense of free speech
it's it's using the state to defend free
speech which i know
seems so crazy to so many on the right
who have thought that that's not
possible over the last couple of decades
the right used to understand not that
long ago the right used to understand of
course that is the case
the through politics we set the
parameters of the free marketplace of
ideas of the
of the marketplace meaning the economy
itself we we set those things and then
we want it to operate freely within
those boundaries
this also tells me ron desantis is
running
this guy is gearing up for 2024 it is so
obvious
and he's setting himself up in a good
position can he go all the way
who knows it's still so early nobody
could guess these things early on but
he's positioning himself very well and
he is showing clarity
on this issue i hope that the
republicans get some clarity too and we
don't just keep
spewing platitudes about leadership and
conviction all right
i'm michael noel's michael knowles show
we'll see you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
board
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nikka geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 on the matt
well show we talk about the things that
matter real issues that affect you your
family our country not just politics but
culture
faith current events all the
fundamentals if they matter to you come
check out the show